you guys veterans day is on thursday and
you know what i realized there is no
army base named after women or african
americans in fact the entire us military
has more bases named after confederate
soldiers than after female or black
veterans so we're gonna fix that tonight
with the wall of people who deserve to
have faces named after them instead of
confederate generals
there are many black women who deserve
to have their names on military bases
instead of confederate generals like
mary tuvastre mary was an enslaved black
woman with a talent for drawing one day
during the civil war she happened to see
a drawing of the confederacy's plans for
a new warship so she pulled out some
tissue paper from her dress traced the
plans walked to dc and handed them to
the navy's chief admiral and when she
did she changed the course of history
because that wasn't just any ship those
were plans for the first ever ironclad
ship it's the reason why the union navy
dominated the seas and why america's
navy is so revered today but there is no
fort two vestry instead we have fort
beauregard named after confederate
general pierre gustav to tom beauregard
who was a traitor and a losing ass [ __ ]
you know who else should have a base
named after them william cathay
william was a freed slave who wanted to
serve his country so he joined the army
rose through the ranks and ended up
serving with the famous buffalo soldiers
then william fell ill and checked into
an army hospital where it was discovered
that he was actually a woman cafe
williams cathay had disguised herself as
a man so she could fight for her country
something that many black women of that
time period did
cathay should have a base named after
her but instead of fort williams we have
fort pickett
named after confederate general george
pickett who fled to canada after the
south lost the war so he was a coward
and a traitor and a losiness [ __ ]
now
fdr didn't care too much for black
people but he made an exception eleanor
roosevelt's friend mary mcleod bethune
mary could have an audience with fdr at
any time and she convinced him to slide
an amendment into a bill that gave
funding to hbcus when the us was
preparing for war the army didn't have
enough pilots so mary convinced the
first lady to tour hbcus where students
were learning to fly at one stop eleanor
went for a plane ride with a black pilot
and that's what convinced the public
that black men could fly planes which
means mary single-handedly paved the way
for the tuskegee airmen
oh to walk the grounds at camp bethune
but instead we have fort hood
named after confederate general john
bell hood who was a traitor and a
loser-ness [ __ ]
and also extremely ugly look at him
he looks like a melting jake gyllenhaal
next up
ariminta ross erimenta ross was a famous
tour guide until the government of
massachusetts begged her to help the
union in the civil war she led the
expeditionary forces on raids trained
soldiers and had such a profound effect
that the general in charge of south
carolina told his troops to free any
slaves they came across now that made
abraham lincoln furious until slaves
started joining the union army it not
only gave the union an advantage it led
to the emancipation proclamation
aramenta even got a pension but it
wasn't under her birth name it was under
her new name
you're gonna flip
harry tubman
ah
fork tubman it has a nice ring to it but
instead we have fort benning which
sounds like trash because it is trash
because it's named after confederate
general henry benning who was trash
he said by the time the north shall have
attained the power the black race will
be in a large majority and then we will
have black governors black legislatures
black juries black everything is it to
be supposed that the white race will
stand for that well have a seat [ __ ]
cause it's happening
now here are some other black women who
are more deserving of having military
bases named after them famous chef and
food network star sonny anderson you
know what she's also famous for not
being a freaking trader
radio talk show host robin quivers she
was a captain in the air force and fort
quivers is just a cool sounding name
or you could also pick my mummy
mommy cute and mommy smart and mommy
served in the air force
another fun fact about mommy she has
never taken up arms against her
government so there you go it's all
fixed
yay we did it
i'm hoping
let's get rid of those embarrassing
losers and let's get into honoring some
real heroes and if you run out of black
female veterans remember any black woman
who has survived america to become an
adult is smarter and stronger and more
deserving than a confederate general
just think about it for beyonce
this has been the wall of people who
deserve to have bases named after them
instead of confederate generals
[Music]
you